2 1 on November 18 2023 Starship took
one step closer to
Mars one day Elon Musk expects the most
powerful rocket ever to carry a 100
people to the red planet unlike the
first test flight in April this flight
achieved a milestone Starship fired its
engines before detaching from the super
heavy booster stage separation start
this complicated maneuver didn't happen
previously as a fuel leak led to a fire
in the booster damaging most of its 33
engines Starship veered off course and
the team had to destroy it over water
for safety reasons can remember the
damage to the Launchpad last time this
time SpaceX reinforced the Launchpad
with a steel plate cooled by 260,000
gallons of
water the plan was to lift off from
Starbase in Bach chica Texas with a
booster splashing down close to shore
while Starship soared before landing in
the Pacific Ocean near Hawaii however at
as Elon is aware not everything goes
according to plans as you can see the
super heavy booster has just experienced
a rapid unscheduled disassembly the
booster exploded in spectacular Fashion
After separating from Starship which is
believed to have self-destructed after
the team lost contact with it 10 minutes
in SpaceX says the lessons learned from
this flight will help improve starship's
reliability after all it took the Falcon
1 four tries before reached orbit and
saved the company from impending death
SpaceX even compiled a video showing all
of its failed attempts to land its
orbital boosters if Mars were not the
eventual Target Elon would not need such
a large rocket that Towers over the SLS
and the Saturn 5 that took us to the
moon it's more than twice the thrust of
a Saturn 5 that's the largest rocket
ever to get to orbit he had already
achieved remarkable success with the
Falcon 9 which has become the world's
most reliable rocket regularly
transporting crew and cargo to the ISS a
lucrative business but wealth was is
never the endgame as elen expressed in
his biography written by Walter Isaacson
I could have made a lot of money but I
could not have made life
multiplanetary the Falcon 9 is not big
enough or powerful enough to go all the
way to Mars not even its larger sibling
the Falcon heavy can do that the Falcons
are also not fully reusable while the
first stage returns to earth and the
payload fairings are fished out of the
sea the second stage is not recovered
Starship is designed as a fully reusable
rocket essential for long duration
missions a capability enhanced by
stainless steel construction like the
con used on the Cyber truck Elon fell in
love with stainless steel a few years
back joking to his team stainless steel
and I should go get a room somewhere
Starship was originally supposed to be
made out of carbon fiber however the
carbon fiber sheets were expensive and
not up to the job even the specialized
expertise that went into them could not
prevent issues like developing wrinkles
Elon knew that if they went the carbon
fiber route this extrapolates to death
I'll never be able to get to Mars he
told Isaac Sin so inspired by the
earliest Atlas rockets that took the
first Americans to orbit he opted for
stainless steel it was an odd move
according to his executive team because
stainless steel is heavier than carbon
fiber but Elon looked at the situation
differently the high melting point of
stainless steel eliminated the need for
as many heat shields to protect Starship
as it re-enters the atmosphere where
temperatures can soar as high as500 100°
C or 2700 de F fewer heat shields mean
the overall weight is reduced and
stainless steel maintains its strength
even when holding super cooled liquid
oxygen and methane which is used to fuel
Starship the first prototype of Starship
was the starhopper which had retractable
legs to test how it could land when it
returns to earth however Elon has since
decided to try to catch Starship both
the ship and the booster with a tower
that holds the rocket on the LaunchPad
the SpaceX team was once again nervous
at such a bold proposal what happens if
the catch fails and destroys the launch
Tower and the next flight is delayed
when someone on X asked why not just use
the landing legs for the booster Elon
replied legs would certainly work but
best part is no part best step is no
step highlighting his preference for
reducing complexity to bring down costs
and make space travel more affordable
he's applied the same principle to the
design of the r engines that power
Starship he wanted to lower the cost of
a single engine prototype from 2 million
to 200,000 this strategy worked for him
in the past when he wanted to buy
refurbished icbms from Russia but found
the cost of $8 million for one too high
and decided to create his own company to
build more affordable Rockets he since
coined the term idiot index a metric
comparing the cost of a component to the
cost of its raw materials let's say the
nozzle for the engine hypothetic Ally
costs $20,000 but the raw material cost
is $2,000 so the ratio on elon's idiot
index would be 10 to one a high ratio
suggests the production process for this
component is more expensive than it
really needs to be when Elon asked
financial analyst Lucas Hughes what are
the best parts in Raptor as judged by
the idiot index and Hughes responded I'm
not sure Elon reamed him out as reported
in isakson's book he said you better be
effing sure in the future you know these
things off the top of your head if you
ever come into a meeting and do not know
what are the idiot parts then your
resignation will be accepted immediately
unbeknownst to Elon the analyst had
other things on his mind he had just
lost a newborn daughter a few weeks
before Elon had suffered a similar loss
when his firstborn Nevada Alexander died
of sudden infant death syndrome when
isacon later asked Elon if he felt he
was being too harsh Elon said I try to
criticize the action not the person we
all know make mistakes what matters is
whether a person has a good feedback
loop can seek criticism from others and
can improve physics does not care about
hurt feelings it cares about whether you
got the rocket right the analyst was
much more prepared the next day he
discovered that Parts with the highest
cost compared to raw material required a
lot of high Precision Machining Elon
decided that the person in charge of
each component should try to get their
costs down by 80% and if they couldn't
they should step aside if someone else
might be able to do so Elon has always
operated with an extreme sense of
urgency as if every second counts
declaring we need to get to Mars before
I die he assigned the responsibility for
revamping Raptor to a young engineer
named Jacob McKenzie the directive in
musk's words was to delete any part that
is even potentially unnecessary McKenzie
consulted a Tesla executive to help
streamline spacex's manufacturing
similar to how Tesla continues to
streamline its process of mass producing
electric vehicles the result is that
version two of the Raptor engine removed
many of the intricate Plumbing
components and looked much simpler you
know V1 looks like kind of like a
Christmas tree spaghetti pile a lot of
fiddly bits um Raptor 2 costs about half
as much as Raptor one despite having
much more thrust it's only going to get
better from here elon's Hands-On
approach is embodied by his choice to
live just a mile away from Star base
despite being the richest person in the
world he resolved Ides in a two-bedroom
house where caffeine-free Diet Cokes are
common as our midnight meetings with a
Starship team living and breathing the
mission to make life
multiplanetary building the most
advanced rockets in the world would not
be possible without the hard work of
brilliant Engineers if you've been
inspired by Elon and the team at SpaceX
and want to brush up on your skills in
math computer science and data science I
highly recommend brilliant a website and
app where you can learn interactively
whether you're aspiring to be part of
the next generation of Space Explorers
or you're simply looking to enhance your
skills no matter your profession
Brilliance interactive lessons can help
you on your journey I personally use
brilliant to improve my analytical
thinking skills by going through their
logic puzzles there's something for
everyone whether you're just starting
out or want to progress to more
challenging puzzles and if you get stuck
you can view the explanation to discover
the correct approach you can try out
brilliant for free for 30 days using my
link in the description brilliant .org
newthink if you're one of the first 200
people to sign up via my link you'll get
20% off your premium subscription
unlocking all of Brilliance courses
thanks for watching for news thinkink
I'm Cindy
pal